[Musica]
c'è qualcuno in sala che non ha mai mai
mai pensato di andare a vivere nello
spazio fosse anche solo per scappare
dalla professoressa di matematica meglio
io da ragazzino devo dire lo facevo
spesso non scappare pensare di vivere
nello spazio e immaginavo di passeggiare
su mondi lontani su pianeti lontanissimi
in foreste di strani alberi incontrando
strani mostri extraterrestri non ero
molto bravo
scrivo dei raccontini anche con delle
figure delle illustrazioni ma mi
venivano malissimo non si andava mai da
nessuna parte non succedeva niente
invece ci sono persone così brave a
scrivere racconti di cannes fantascienza
che a volte fanno anticipare il futuro
l'esempio classico è quello di jules
verne che a metà dell'ottocento scrive
una trilogia che parla di viaggi sulla
luna e poi il 20 luglio del 69
l'apollo 11 all'una apre la sua
porticina e scendono armstrong e aldrin
e con i loro doppi passi quel piccolo
passo per l'uomo che sarà diventato un
enorme passo per l'umanità
beh però oggi il privilegio di inventare
il futuro non è più soltanto gli
scrittori di fantascienza e di
scienziati chiaramente ma anche di altre
persone per esempio con gli imprenditori
che decidono di rilanciare progetti come
il turismo spaziale o le colonie su
marte ma perché c'è tutto questo
interesse all'esplorazione dello spazio
la prima cosa è chiara è semplicissimo
superare il limite andare oltre l'innato
istinto all'esplorazione dell'essere
umano che poi anche un po alla base del
progresso
però ci sono anche motivazioni un po più
pratiche per esempio quelle di poter
controllare la terra dall'alto e che per
motivi strategici che siano militari o
commerciali chiaramente è importante per
molte persone
ovviamente ci sono anche altri motivi
forse un poco più delicati per esempio
se pensate all
storia della vita sulla terra una buona
parte delle specie che sono vissute
sulla terra sono estinte in buona parte
vuol dire quasi tutte allora una volta è
stato magari la cometa boom una volta i
vulcani qualche volta cambiamento
climatico ce n'è sempre per tutti allora
in queste condizioni avere una colonia
con degli umani che vivono fuori dal
pianeta un po al riparo da queste
possibili situazioni potrebbe non essere
una cattiva idea
viste queste motivazioni ben vengano
questi visionari dello spazio uno di
loro si chiama igor assorbe il i ed è
uno scienziato miliardario che poi anche
io mi ero scritta fisica per diventare
miliardario però le cose non sono andate
molto bene invece igor c'è riuscito e
forse era ricco anche da prima è nella
nella sua visionarietà ha lanciato un
progetto un paio di anni fa un progetto
veramente fantascientifico il regno
spaziale diaz guardian si tratta proprio
di quello di un progetto di costruire
una nazione che sia basato nello spazio
può essere su basi lunari su un grappolo
di stazioni spaziali orbitanti o su
marte dovunque si riesca ad arrivare il
regno specialità scardia per ora è
soltanto una una associazione
un'organizzazione non governativa con
sede a vienna e si sta occupando un po
di tutti quei passaggi che servono per
diventare una vera nazione e vuol dire
essenzialmente avere dei cittadini avere
una popolazione un governo intessere
relazioni internazionali e questi sono
tutti i passaggi che si stanno pian
piano iniziando a fare la cosa è
veramente molto recente come avete visto
ci sono già quasi 200mila persone che
hanno fatto domanda per diventare
cittadini
potete farlo anche voi se volete basta
andare sul loro sito accettare la
costituzione fare domanda è chiaramente
ed è facile fra questi ci sono circa 8
mila italiani
sottolineo non si tratta soltanto di
invasati di fantascienza e cose varie
ci sono molte persone del settore
spaziale anche scienziati ingegneri e
cose del genere quindi non è tutto
caschi di star wars il parlamento come
come diceva prima alessandro è stato
nominato da poco da un mese e poco più
e a fine giugno ci sarà la prima
riunione in cui si insiederà al
parlamento nominerà il governo e
inizierà ad essere quella struttura
legale che è necessaria per diventare un
vero stato il territorio va bene per ora
è piccolino satellite grande più o meno
quanto una scatola di scarpe si chiama
scardia uno è stato messo in orbita lo
scorso ottobre e sta quindi girando
intorno alla luna però nei primi nei
prossimi 5 10 anni è previsto che questa
flotta aumenti e in particolare che si
aggiungano dei moduli abitabili sul tipo
di quelli della stazione spaziale
internazionale per capirci in versione
economica perché se no nun se po fa bene
le cose da fare sono ancora tantissime
forse la più complicata di tutte
l'ultima è quella che serve per
diventare una vera nazione essere
accettati dall'onu e dalle altre nazioni
del pianeta terra
su tutte queste cose asgardiana sta
lavorando pian piano per raggiungere nei
tempi necessari
stiamo parlando forse di un gruppo di
fanatici di fantascienza appunto che
dice sveglia e dice beh oggi andiamo a
vivere sullo spazio questa è una cosa
che sapremo nei prossimi anni quando
vedremo gli sviluppi di questa avventura
però di sicuro parlare di asgard e ci
permette di cercare di capire un po
quale sia lo stato dell'arte di due
sfide molto importanti per andare a
vivere nello spazio la sfida scientifico
tecnologica è la sfida etico politica la
sfida scientifica tecnologica e già
chiaramente in corso da da abbastanza e
ci sono siamo diventati molto molto
bravi sappiamo per esempio installare
dei laboratori di ricerca lassù nella
stazione spaziale da 400 chilometri dove
gli astronauti fanno i loro esperimenti
tutti i giorni
oppure siamo in grado di mandare il
rover su marte con la trivellin a
scavare a prendere i suoi campioni ea
studiare il suolo e nei prossimi mesi e
anche anni partiranno due sonde spaziali
scientifiche che andranno come icaro si
avvicenderanno tantissimo al sole per
prendere delle misure come il calo
speriamo di no ma speriamo che non si
sciolgano queste che devono funzionare
se no siamo messi male però c'è ancora
tanto da fare avete visto prima quello
che fanno
all'agenzia spaziale europea per capire
quali siano gli effetti di possibili
della vita nello spazio andando in
mandando un po di poveracci in in
antartide succede veramente tantissimo
da fare e altri problemi
oltre a quelli della salute delle
reazioni del corpo umano all'esposizione
radiazioni e microgravità ci sono anche
altri problemi bisogna rendere sia i
materiali che i vettori o comunque la
strumentazione spaziale molto più
economica più sostenibile perché sennò
dove andiamo
questi problemi sono al cuore
dell'attività di asgard ii in quanto
nazione quindi a scardia può aggredire
questi problemi in maniera con un
impatto notevole
questo perché perché contrariamente alle
altre nazioni a scardia i cittadini del
guardian sono accomunati non tanto dal
colore della pelle dalla lingua dalla
storia come succede di solito ma
piuttosto dal desiderio comune di andare
a vivere lassù nello spazio quindi
questo da una tasca di una enorme massa
critica che può contribuire
all'avanzamento di questa di questa
sfida
io sono abbastanza ottimista prima o poi
si farà potrebbe essere fra cinque anni
potrebbe essere tra 150 anni
non c'è dato sapere però una cosa la
strada è intrapresa e questo è molto
importante
non solo il fatto che questa sfida penso
si vinca ci porta naturalmente la
seconda sfida quella etica riusciremo a
farlo in modo sostenibile
allo stato attuale ci sono dei trattati
internazionali che di fatto proteggono
lo spazio come se lo proteggessero
dall'aggressiva
l'uomo come una riserva naturale non si
può fare praticamente niente
nello spazio che sia al di sopra di una
certa quota bene così
nessuno si fa del male siamo a posto
però chiaramente con gli interessi
commerciali militari di cui sopra è
chiaro che i trattati internazionali
possono tenere ma anche no
ecco in quel caso potrebbero esserci dei
problemi sullo sfruttamento eccessivo
dello spazio e questo non potrebbe non
essere una bella cosa bella sguardi
anche qui propone un punto di vista un
po diverso
anziché guardare allo spazio come un
qualcosa da sfruttare da parte di
nazioni multinazionali
bisogna guardarlo con una risorsa da
utilizzare in maniera sostenibile per la
comunità intera e questo è possibile
solo se si baserà l'approccio allo
spazio su principi universali che sono
quelli di pace uguaglianza cercare del
progresso e proteggere l'ambiente sia
quello terrestre che è quello extra
terrestre
questi principi sono al cuore della
costituzione di us guardian e
rappresentano veramente le basi quindi a
scardia ha la possibilità di nuovo di
iniziare quantomeno non dico di vincere
la sfida perché è una sfida grande ma
quantomeno di istradare l'attività verso
questo tipo di approccio basato su
principi universali e non su la
protezione di un gruppo particolare di
persone che di solito potrebbe
costituire una nazione l'era spaziale è
iniziata da ormai più di mezzo secolo si
fanno progressi continuamente e sempre
sempre più belli e siamo sempre più
vicini a poter andare a vivere nello
spazio progetti come quello di us
guardian possono spingere la comunità
internazionale gli altri stati ad
adottare strumenti sia scientifici che
tecnologici che etici e politici che
siano più moderni più adatti più evoluti
per poter conquistare lo spazio in
maniera sostenibile completamente
sostenibile e poter magari creare una
casa verde lassù dove
ad abitare un giorno e forse guardare
anche alla terra a quel punto con un po
più di attenzione se siamo bravi ad
imparare da queste cose io credo che
questi possano essere concetti di un
futuro un po utopistico
può darsi non sappiamo mai se al
guardian diventerà veramente una realtà
però sono sicuro che la strada
illustrata da sgarbi a proposta da
guardia per risolvere queste due sfide
sia la migliore possibile per la
evoluzione della specie umana nel lungo
termine e quindi se qualcuno spinge un
po per accelerare in questa direzione
ben venga beh forse penserete che ho
parlato veramente di fantascienza di
cose strane però chiedetevi un po quale
sia veramente la distanza e dove sia il
limite fra il presente il futuro e dove
sia il limite fra la fantasia e la
realtà
vi invito andare a guardare qualche buon
vecchio film di fantascienza dove
potreste trovare delle risposte
interessanti e sorprendenti grazie
[Musica]